-Joe. I'm excited you're here.
We're gonna talk sneakers.
I want to talk about
all this stuff.
And we actually might even show
what may be Sneaker of the Year.
-Maybe. Yes.
-We're not sure. Yeah.
-We're gonna debate it
right here.
-What got you interested?
Do you remember?
Like, what got you started
with sneakers?
-I was always into sneakers.
And then my first job, 16,
was at a sneaker store.
Finish Line.
South Shore Mall in Bay Shore.
Shout-out to my hometown.
-Yeah.
-And it was funny because, like,
the screening process
to get the job wasn't, like,
you have to interview.
It was literally like,
"Hey, this store is opening up.
Put your name and birthday
on a 8x11 sheet of paper."
And if you could do that,
you're hired.
-Yeah. There you go.
And you did that?
-I did that correctly.
I did that correctly.
But it was awesome
because, like,
I worked with, like,
all my track team.
It was, like, my first job,
and it was like 20 of us
are working there.
-That's the best.
-They lasted like 2 or 3 months
and I lasted like 8 years,
on and off, so...
-You really got dedicated.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And do you remember --
do you remember
the first pair of sneakers
that got you excited?
-My parents were really good
because they, like,
got me the one pair every year
that was, like, the pair.
May have been, like,
only one pair a year,
but it was, like, the pair,
first day of school.
I remember in ninth grade,
in 1997,
the Air Max 97 came out.
Great, great shoe.
I'm sure Quest knows.
Quest is a big sneakerhead.
-Yes, he is. Yeah. Tariq, too.
-And -- Exactly.
Tariq, as well.
And the Air Max 97.
I remember, like,
the first day of school.
Ninth grade, you're always
nervous to go to high school,
and, like, I, like,
laid out the outfit
and had the Air Max 97
with, like, the --
It was like a person
in my bedroom just laid out.
-Oh, yeah.
-And the shoes at the bottom.
So that one -- that sticks out
when I was like 14 or 15.
-Yeah. Did you keep --
Do you keep the box?
-I keep the boxes now, but they
take up too much room now.
-Oh, now. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember. Yeah.
I didn't really have
the greatest sneakers growing up
because I kept
growing out of them.
My parents were getting mad.
They were like, "Stop growing.
It's costing us too much money."
-And they take up
a lot of space.
Yeah. So they were like -- Yeah.
I had, like, one pair
and I would, like,
squeeze out of them.
They're like, "Alright. Fine.
Let's get him, you know..."
But I remember when I --
when I did stand-up,
I would wear Nikes
because Jerry Seinfeld
wore Nikes on "Seinfeld."
And so I go, "That's good luck.
I'm going to wear Nikes."
And that was my thing
for a while.
-So I need, like,
a favor from you
because he hasn't done
"Sneaker Shopping" yet.
And Jerry -- What you just said.
Jerry is known --
On "Seinfeld," he had, like
such classic '90s sneakers,
and they were switching it out
almost like every episode.
-Yeah.
-Can you put in the word?
Can you put in the word?
-Yes. He would be a great guest.
Jerry.
You got to do "Sneaker Shopping"
with Joe La Puma.
You got to do it.
-We need it. We need it.
-We have some --
We have some sneakers here.
Explain to me. What are these?
-So, we just had DJ Khaled
on this week's episode.
-He's the best.
-The best. The best.
-What did he call you?
-He called me Jay Pluma.
Fine. It's okay.
-Jay Pluma?
-Yeah.
Instead of Joe La Puma,
he called me Jay Pluma.
It's fine. If anyone can get --
If anyone can get away with it,
it's DJ Khaled.
But he's been here,
and you know his energy.
When you film with DJ Khaled,
he's the host,
he's the producer,
he's the director,
and he's the guest.
-He's everything.
-So you just have to keep --
-He's the camera operator.
He's everything. Yeah.
Don't mess with it.
-And you have to
keep up with him.
But the spoiler alert is,
you can't keep up with him.
-No.
-So, we had him on the show.
It was the second time
we had him on the show.
The first time we had him
was 2015, I think.
But in 2018,
he sent me these shoes,
which was
a very rare collaboration
that he did with Jordan.
He actually did
a Jordan collaboration
that's in stores last year,
but this was, like,
friends and family.
It showed up to
the Complex office once.
And super-rare pair.
I, like, checked.
In our sizes --
I know your size.
-Thank you.
-They're fetching
almost $25,000.
-What?!
-Yeah. Yeah.
-$25,000 for sneakers?
-Yeah.
So it's, like,
a very special gift
that he gave me
out of my collection.
And the "We the Best."
You know, that's his tagline.
And these are called
the Another One 3's.
If anyone knows --
If anyone knows Khaled,
that's one of
his many catchphrases.
-Yeah. I did a sneaker collab
with MSCHF.
-I saw that.
-Do you know those guys?
-The Big Red Boots.
-Big Red Boots is MSCHF.
-Yes. Everyone know
the Big Red Boots?
How -- Did you guys see those?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're crushing it.
-They're troublemakers.
-Well, everyone says like,
"Oh, we want to disrupt."
They're real disruptors.
And you had --
you had your own collab
that you took super-serious.
-I did.
-Yeah.
-I was very proud of these.
They're called Gobstompers.
And the idea of them were --
they're like Gobstoppers.
They're white sneakers,
but the more you wore them
and beat them up,
the colors would change
'cause there's different
layers of color.
-Look at it.
-So this is my sneaker.
And to be really honest,
you had --
-Yeah.
-You really have to --
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But this is them undistressed.
This is them
if you just wore them clean.
-Almost 20 years --
-And then this is -- But, yeah.
And this is what you do
if you mess them up.
But what I found out was they'll
never really look like this.
You have to take, like,
a belt sander to them.
-So that happens --
that happens a lot.
A lot of brands are doing
pre-distressed sneakers,
and you're like,
"Oh, these are --
I'm gonna wear them around
for a few days
and they're gonna
start peeling off."
You really have to
take, like, sandpaper to them
for it to happen.
-This will never happen
unless you really take
a belt sander.
-Years.
-It won't -- It will never ha--
They'll look like this.
That was the thing.
So really you get
a pair of these Gobstompers
and get a belt sander and
then make them look like that.
And that's -- there you go.
They look cool.
-But I love that you did that
because you're taught
that sneakers
have to be super-pristine.
And for a lot of pairs,
you know, the Khaled ones,
you would not want
to beat those up.
They're very expensive.
But there is something to say
about distressed sneakers
which put some character
into the shoes, so...
-Yeah. No one has the same pair
of these --
Well, unless they're these.
-Exactly.
-Yeah. It's a lot.
It's very deep.
Alright. So you --
So, now, what --
what is Sneaker of the Year
and explain to me.
When is this? ComplexCon?
-ComplexCon.
-It's next month.
-November 18th and 19th
in Long Beach.
We do it every year,
and the premise was basically
taking everything you see
that's cool on the Internet
and turning it into
a real-life convention.
So every year I host
a Sneaker of the Year panel.
It's a very heated debate.
DJ Clark Kent is one
of the panelists who --
Quest, again.
Quest, you know DJ Clark Kent.
One of the biggest
sneaker collectors.
And we kind of go in
with a list of 10,
and then after the hour,
the list of 10
is, like, thrown out the window
because it's very, very
highly debated.
-And you're yelling and yelling
over each other.
Then one is voted
Sneaker of the Year.
-One is voted
-And you brought us
the top four maybe. Or the --
-No, they're gonna be
in the top 10, I think,
but, again, we have
a few months left of 2023.
-I'm not gonna get into
a heated debate with you,
but I will -- I will tell you
what my favorites are.
Here we go right here.
-Yeah. So these are some picks.
-Alright. Walk me through these.
-This is a Tiffany Air Force 1.
Luxury brand. Tiffany & Co.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Some buttery suede
and, like, the Tiffany colorway
on the swoosh.
-Yeah. It's kind of
a gorgeous shoe.
Yeah, I do like these a lot.
Alright. That's on my list.
-Okay.
These are from space.
-Yeah. So this is a --
this is a very loud pair.
It's Drake's NOCTA Nike collab.
It's called the NOCTA Glide.
And I actually wore those.
I wore those.
But Drake has had
a few collabora--
Drake has had a few
collaborations with Nike,
but I really feel like
he nailed this one.
It's based on, like,
a old Jason Kidd
basketball sneaker
from the '90s.
-I love Drake, so I'm gonna
give these points,
but this is not gonna win.
-Okay. Oh. Alright.
-No. This is the lead so far.
-This one?
-This one's in the lead so far.
Yeah. How about this guy?
-A triple collab.
-Triple collab?
-So, the Sambas. I'm sure
you guys know the Sambas.
The Adidas Samba's having a big
moment all over the streets.
-Yeah.
This is a triple collab
by Ronnie Fieg,
who's a friend of mine,
from KITH.
He took a Clarks Wallabee sole
and redid the Adidas Samba
with the Clarks Wallabee sole.
So it's a triple collab between
KITH, Adidas, and Clarks.
-Wow. I like this.
-Yeah.
-Alright. These two so far --
These two are in the lead.
But I don't know.
This might be a curveball here.
-So this is the front-runner.
This, I think,
is the front-runner.
It's a Jordan 4,
which is an iconic silhouette.
And it's a --
it's a skateboarding sneaker.
A collab with Nike SB.
Skateboarders for Nike
tested it for like two years,
wear-tested it,
and it went kind of from
the basketball court back --
Okay. What do we think?
-I mean, that's what I'm saying.
-Wait. Was this --
Was this 2023?
-No, I don't.
-Oh, wait. This wasn't --
-No. This is from last year.
-You're disqualified.
-I already lost last year.
Was I in the top 10 at least?
Alright. So, wait.
-We have to check.
-We got to check.
-You're in my top 10 for sure.
-I think it's gonna be
one of these three.
What do you guys think?
I think it's gonna be
one of these three.
I think this guy's kind of
classy. I like the green.
I like the pop of it.
-Gum sole.
-I think -- I think
these are kind of cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're kind of classy.
But I do like the -- I do like
the Wallabee bottom to it, too.
And I like a little
"ah-dee-dahs" there
to mix it up a little bit.
I -- Ugh.
-There's pressure.
-Yeah.
-Are you ready for the Internet
to come after you over --
-Yeah. Bring it. Bring it.
I don't care. Yeah, please.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah, please.
Do you think I care?
I got my own sneaker, buddy.
I don't care. I'm gonna say --
Get rid of these guys.
I do love Drake.
Tiffany. I think they'll do fine
without winning this.
-Right, right, right.
-They're doing okay.
It's one of --
-Wow. Okay.
-It's down to these two.
And I think the winner is...
[ Drum roll ]
This one.
-Okay.
-That's the winner right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Listen. Listen.
-I said it! I said it!
I said what I had to say!
-That's the front-runner.
That's the front-runner.
-Oh, it is the front-runner.
-Yeah. So you're right on trend.
-Oh, wait. But it already
is the front-runner?
-That's what people --
We'll see.
We'll see in November.
-I'm gonna go back to this one.
-No, no, no. You're good.
Stick with your gut. But people
love -- love this shoe.
The marrying of Nike SB
and Jordan on a Jordan 4.
And you can skate in it.
I saw your promo with MSCHF.
You were skateboarding
a little bit.
-Of course. I skateboard
all the time at work.
Are you kidding me?
I'm Mr. Skateboard.
"Jimmy, where's your board?"
-I saw that.
-Joe La Puma. Thank you so much
for coming to the show.
We know we love you
and come back, okay?
-Before we go. Before we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before we go, when
I interviewed you on my show,
we talked about the Air Max 95.
I think you wore it to, like,
the Kids' Choice Awards in 2004.
And, you know, you're back
to work, back to school.
A new Air Max 95 for you.
-Yo! Come on, bud!
That's what I'm talking about!
That's my size!
12.5.
That's my jam right there.
Come on! That's my dude!
You don't have to do that.
-Come on.
-I got you. You're good.
-Joe La Puma.
Check out new episodes
of "Sneaker Shopping"
Mondays on YouTube.